Ruby Rose looks sensational in her Batwoman
costume, as the DC Comics superheroine prepares
to make the leap from page to screen.
The newest character in the CW's Arrowverse
hasn't quite touched down just yet, but the
network has gone ahead and released a first
official look at how the character will appear
when she makes her debut in an upcoming crossover
event.
To sum it up, she looks fierce, comics-accurate,
and perfectly-coiffed.
The cape looks nice, too.
And all this just in time for Halloween.
Rose was cast as Batwoman in August, around
a month after reports first emerged that the
CW was developing a live-action Batwoman series.
The new show will compliment the other DC
Comics superhero series on the network a lineup
which currently includes Arrow, The Flash,
Legends of Tomorrow, Supergirl, and Black
Lightning.
Unlike Black Lightning, which has so far largely
stood on its own in the CW's superhero slate,
Batwoman will associate itself with the other
heroes of the Arrowverse right from the jump.
Prior to heading up her own series, the Batwoman
character will make her first appearance in
the three-part Arrowverse crossover event
"Elseworlds", which is set to begin on Sunday,
December 9 with an episode of The Flash.
The event will continue in an episode of Arrow
on Monday, December 10 and conclude with an
episode of Supergirl on Tuesday, December
11.
The Batwoman series proper will then follow
sometime in 2019.
While details on the story of the "Elseworlds"
crossover are somewhat scarce, the title alone
seems to imply that the Arrowverse will once
again be indulging in some alternate universe
shenanigans, as it has to great effect in
past crossover episodes like "Crisis On Earth-X".
DC has also announced that the team-up event
will introduce comics character The Monitor,
a nearly-omnipotent, Multiverse-hopping entity
played by Designated Survivor's LaMonica Garrett.
The crossover will also feature first-ever
appearances from famed DC Comics reporter
Lois Lane, as well as the character Nora Fries,
better known as the wife of Mr. Freeze, whose
death notoriously drove the Gotham City villain
to a vengeful life of crime.
Will the Flash, Arrow and Supergirl team up
to help Batwoman take on Mr. Freeze?
There's got to be more to it than that.
Mr. Freeze isn't that threatening.
"Da blood will FREEEEEZE in ma hands!"
According to the CW, the crossover will follow
the established Arrowverse heroes (minus the
Legends of Tomorrow) as they travel to Gotham
City, presumably on some sort of crime-fighting
adventure.
The question is, which Gotham City will they
be going to?
We know from Arrow and Supergirl that a Gotham
City exists on those two characters' Earths,
so will this be the Gotham of Earth-One, Earth-Thirty-Eight,
or another Earth we haven't visited before?
The opportunities are endless.
"How many are there?"
"Infinite."
The particular version of Batwoman that Rose
will be playing is Kate Kane, who has been
presented in the comics as a wealthy heiress
in the Gotham City social scene.
While we haven't seen her in action yet, reports
say that the character will be portrayed as
an out-and-proud lesbian and capable street
fighter who is at first reluctant to don the
cape, the cowl, and the big red wig.
Aren't they always, though?
You can't take up a Bat-mantle without at
least a little inner turmoil.
"Do you want to talk about how you're feeling
right now?"
I don't talk about feelings.
I don't have any, Alfred, I've never seen
one.
I'm a night stalking, crime fighting, vigilante."
It's hard to imagine how you could get much
closer to a live-action version of the comic
book look than this.
Specifically, the design of the costume for
the TV series seems to be taking inspiration
from the version of the getup popularized
by the DC Comics series, 52.
The most distinguishing feature of the getup
is the voluminous shock of red hair cascading
out the back of the Batwoman cowl, which could
be mesmerizing to see in motion if it's done
well.
It's already a better red wig than the one
Marvel stuck poor Medusa with on that Inhumans
show.
The one thing this costume snapshot doesn't
address is where Batwoman intends to carry
all her stuff.
That's a pretty slim utility belt, after all;
Maybe the cape has pockets.
Or maybe they're still planning on outfitting
Batwoman with her classic, 1950-era Bat-Purse
accessory, for those nights when she needs
to carry around a change of shoes along with
the baton and Batarangs.
These are the kinds of things you have to
think about when you're a fashion-forward
crime fighter Batman and Robin have it easy.